bonjour damien abad bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoints vous
êtes député de l'ain président du groupe
l'est républicain à l'assemblée
nationale et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christelle
patron du groupe la dépêche bonjour
castel bonjour yanbu chaque jour damien
abad on va commencer en parlant de la
crise des sous-marins évidemment ou qui
continuent de faire l'actualité crise
diplomatique notamment vous avez demandé
vous une commission d enquête
parlementaire sur le sujet pour faire la
lumière sur cette crise et sur le lait
la manière des explications sur pourquoi
finalement l'australie a rompu son
contrat ce que cette commission denquête
elle va aboutir
malheureusement non parce que nous
n'avons plus de droits de tirage des
groupes politiques à l'assemblée
nationale depuis le mois de juillet donc
seul le prise en assemblée nationale est
ce la conférence des présidents peut
décider de cette commission denquête je
les demande et au nom du groupe l'est
républicain parce que je pensais de
commission denquête est utile et
nécessaire pour faire la lumière sur ces
dysfonctionnements le président
l'assemblée nationale a proposé que
signé mission d'information qui se met
en place intercommission donc il y aura
une mission d'information qui va se
mettre en place à l'assemblée nationale
pour la commission de la défense des
affaires étrangères et des affaires
économiques parce qu'on a besoin de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé les
retards les négligences et
éventuellement de savoir que ce que le
gouvernement avait comme information et
quels ont été les signes avant-coureurs
donc richard ferrand refuser la
commission denquête si on comprend bien
vous a donné une explication on vous
savez je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait
que cette commission denquête
malheureusement soit refusée par le
pouvoir en place ça a été comme cela
depuis cinq ans on voit bien qu'on veut
très vite mettre la poussière sur le
tapis il en a besoin de comprendre
maintenant le sénat pour éventuellement
reprendre cette commission denquête la
porte et j'ai vu que bruno retailleau
lui-même se s'interroger sur
l'opportunité d'avoir cette commission
denquête moi je pense qu'elle est
nécessaire qu'elle est utile et qu'elle
sera bienvenu et non pas dans un esprit
polémique mais pour comprendre parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la place de la
france dans le monde mais c'est surtout
quand même un échec massif pour la
france et la relation les landes et
samatan sénateurs de votre compte
moi je après je suis à bruno retailleau
de de faire ce choix là mais mais en
tout cas je pense que si ce choix est
fait par les sénateurs du groupe de
bruno et bien nous le soutiendrons avec
force est ce que ça veut dire que vous
avez des doutes que vous pensez que le
gouvernement plus cacher des choses on
sait faire j'ai les interrogations
d'abord sur la manière de la diplomatie
française s'est comporté dans cette
affaire là pourquoi si on savait qu'il y
avait des signes avant coureurs pourquoi
on n'a pas réagi avant pourquoi
finalement on n'a pas compris
diplomatiquement
interroger nos alliés je vois bien que
la sur réaction du ministre des affaires
étrangères interrogent elles mêmes et on
voit bien que la réalité c'est que je
pense qu'il ya eu effectivement une
certaine négligence même si encore une
fois c'est aussi l'attitude des états
unis c'est aussi l'attitude de nos
alliés avec n'est pas acceptable et
c'est aussi cela qui doit être interrogé
si la place de la france dans le monde
donc oui c'est un ensemble de choses qui
nous amène malheureusement à ce qui
était un contrat du siècle devient un
fléau du siècle emmanuel macron est-ce
qu'il doit s'exprimer sur ce sujet pour
vous on entend pas on entend beaucoup
j'aime le drian florence parle et on a
entendu des voix aux européennes s'est
exprimé seul avant d'aller en entendu
nicolas sarkozy hier soutenir emmanuel
macron à ce que le chef de l'état doit
prendre la parole nicolas sarkozy hier
il a soutenu la france est la raison de
soutenir la france et la place de la
france dans le monde ensuite je pense
que oui le présent république doit
s'exprimer sur ce sujet mais doit pas
s'exprimer pour rien dire et doit
s'exprimer pour pour une fois qu'il
aurait eu un échange avec joe biden une
fois que j'espère les choses auront
avancé dans le bon sens et une fois que
je dirais il ya eu réparation entre
guillemets pour la france
tactiquement je comprends pourquoi il ne
le fait pas je pense que tant qu'il n'y
a pas d'annoncés concrètes à faire aux
français il ne le fera pas mais je pense
qu'il doit s'exprimer parce que tous les
autres se sont exprimés des chefs de
gouvernement notamment et c'est
important parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
besoin de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
de rassurer aussi parce que la france
est aussi une grande puissance
exportatrice et que donc et bien le
climat économique mondial a besoin
également d'être rassurés vous
rencontrer le premier ministre ce soir
jean castex ce sera un des sujets de vos
discussions bon je crois pas je crois
que
le sujet va tourner essentiellement
autour de la crise sanitaire de la
question de la prolongation du pass
sanitaires et la question de la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et justement on va en parler
de cette prolongation du passé ni terre
et un conseil de défense sanitaire ce
matin mais il y aura un projet de loi ça
a été annoncé projet de loi le 13
octobre prochain pour prolonger ce passé
un été à ce que vous êtes favorable
écoutez si la situation épidémique le
nécessitent oui parce que le pass
sanitaire permet le maintien de lieux
publics ouverts et permet aussi de se
protéger face à une épidémie qui est
encore là malgré tout maintenant je
souhaite que l'on pose aussi la question
de la levée des gestes barrières
notamment la question du masque en lieu
clos dans les salles de réunion là où on
utilise le pass anitea on peut avoir
recours pas sanitaire parce que on
pourra pas non plus at vitam aeternam
vivre sous cloche avec un pass annie
terre et avec des gestes barrières
permanent il faudra commander on se pose
la question et la deuxième chose c'est
que j'y suis favorable à une condition
c'est que cette prolongation ne se fasse
pas jusqu'à après l'élection
présidentielle mais qu'il faut aussi
qu'on ait des clauses de rendez vous au
parlement le parlement siège jusqu'au
mois de février et je pense qu'une
progression jusqu'au mois de février
serait la bienvenue et parce qu'il faut
que le parlement soit associé à tout
simplement prise de décision sur la
crise sanitaire alors dans le même temps
le président de la république a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises la possibilité de
lever le pass sanitaire dans certaines
régions où le nombre de contaminations
est en baisse quand qu'est ce que vous
en pensez on a toujours défendu la
territorialisation de l'action sanitaire
après je m'interroge toujours parce que
vous savez les français ils se déplacent
ici les vacances approchent des vacances
approchent donc je suis pas sûr que
large sur la question du pass and it et
en tant que tel la territorialisation
sur le meilleur outil est l'outil le
plus adapté je pense que je préférais
que à la limite se sont peut-être sur la
levée d'un certain nombre de gestes
barrières mais ça on ne peut pas y avoir
des problèmes si vous enlevez le masque
dans les yeux que dans les lieux clos
juste parce que vous avez un passé une
terre vous savez très bien qu'on peut
être vaccinés dont vraiment vacciner et
quand même être porteur du
demande au nez il ya aussi des moments
où on a le pass annie terre comment
restaurant et on enlève le masque le
risque zéro n'existe pas on ne peut pas
avoir non plus une société du risque
zéro qui met à mal les libertés et qui
finalement fait qu'être vitam aeternam
on est dans un système de parapluies
permanent est ce que du coup vous seriez
favorable à la vaccination pour tous moi
j'ai toujours dit que la vaccination
pour tous et est moins hypocrite que le
pad sanitaires je le pense toujours
parce que le passé ni terre c'était une
forme de vaccination pour tous déguisés
qui ne disait pas son nom en tant que
tel voilà maintenant la question ne se
pose plus parce que
il y aura un débat là-dessus puisque les
sénateurs socialistes déposé un texte
sur la vaccination obligatoire pour tous
maintenant maintenant elle est
généralisée de la réalité qui
je pense que maintenant c'est maintenant
c'est les choses sont faites sur 50
millions de français qui sont vaccinées
par contient un sujet il ya un sujet
notamment sur les personnes fragiles et
vulnérables et notamment les plus de 80
ans on a du retard en france et on doit
rattraper sur ôta ou là très clairement
on doit en tout cas avoir une incitation
beaucoup plus forte sur ce public là
parce que je pense que c'est là dessus
où il faut agir et c'est là-dessus où la
france a encore du retard dans la
vaccination comment on fait d'abord une
incitation plus forte peut-être avec par
l'intermédiaire du médecin traitant je
pense que ces personnages ont aussi
besoin pour certaines d'être rassuré
certaines d'être convaincu également il
faut de la petite explication la
pédagogie il faut vraiment une
incitation parce que c'est là on a un
risque et c'est là où on peut avoir
malheureusement une reprise plus forte
dans les réanimations on va parler
finances budget puisque c'est
aujourd'hui la présentation du dernier
et on a l'impression que depuis quelques
semaines le chef de l'état a sorti son
chéquier on parle du chèque énergie du
minimum
retraite peut-être dans le plfss
est ce que tout ça était bien nécessaire
après le plan de relance est ce que
c'est un bon signal envoyé est ce que
c'est rassurant pour les français ou
est-ce que c'est trop de dépenses en
même temps on la vérité c'est que le
président de la république y propose aux
français avec ce budget un jeu concours
qui s'appelle qui veut gagner des
milliards la réalité c'est quoi c'est
que il utilise le chéquier de la france
à des fins électorales il est en
campagne quand il reçut un le quoi qu'il
en coûte sanitaires oui nous on a
toujours soutenu toutes les aides qu
vide et toute aide d'urgence en faveur
de l'économie française mais là on est
passé à 1 quoi qu'il en coûte électorale
et la vérité c'est que ce sont les
français qui vont trinquer parce que on
va au lendemain de la dépense sans faire
aucune réforme structurelle ni la
réforme des retraites ni celle de
l'assurance chômage 10 celle de l'état a
informé donc on va augmenter la dette et
donc les impôts sur les français passent
et l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
par exemple qu'est ce qu'on fait et
français commençaient à avoir du mal à
cela a payé tout ça mais d'abord ce
qu'on s'attaque aux causes il ya une
augmentation du prix de l'énergie et
dans le même temps le gouvernement
français n'est toujours pas capable de
sortir des 6e père qui l'avait promis
pour développer la filière nucléaire en
france en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait
là les français ils vont parce que les
prix de l'énergie augmentent est-ce que
vous n'auriez pas augmenter le chakana
mais aussi par exemple c'est parce que
je dis bien entendu qu'on peut avoir des
mesures de soutien sectoriel je pensais
à la question du prix d'électricité
d'énergie je pense aussi à la question
de la taxe sur les carburants on a été
un des premiers à droite a demandé à
cheikh carburant le mettre en place dans
certaines régions parce qu'on sait le
surcoût que ça génère mais je dis aussi
que l'échec ne suffiront pas et que sur
la question période du prix
d'électricité quand on démantèle notre
filière nucléaire et bien c'est
augmenter aussi les prix il faut le dire
aux français et la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que ce gouvernement qui hésitent
qui sur le nucléaire qui n'a pas une
politique très claire et bien demain il
a eu les gilet jaune il peut avoir
effectivement les gilet bleu avec des
gens qui viennent dans la rue en
dénonçant c'est osk permanente qui abîme
et qui affecte le pouvoir d'achat des
français donc il ya une action aussi à
faire sur les causes est l'une des
causes c'est de développer le nucléaire
pour maintenir un prix d'électricité un
étage entier une nouvelle fracture oui
bien sûr la fracture territoriale de
toute façon on est toujours là elle n'a
pas disparu malheureusement et que
aujourd'hui les ruraux les territoires
ruraux en temps elles vont encore une
fois subir des coups de chance parce que
le prix d'énergie mais aussi le prix des
carburants qui augmente et ça c'est un
coup terrible pour le pouvoir d'achat
des français et notamment de celles et
ceux qui vivent dans la france des
territoires on peut terminer sur ces
questions budgétaires demain aura lieu
ici au sénat un séminaire des
républicains sur la question du quoi
qu'il en coûte le quoi qu'il en coûte
jusqu'où c'est l'intitulé de votre
séminaire et aurore bergé elle était à
votre place la députée la réplique en
marche elle disait les républicains il
nous critiquent beaucoup sur la question
des dépenses mais dans leurs
propositions il ya que des dépenses et
n'y a pas d'économie qu est-ce qu on l
attendait qu'elle est de mauvaise foi
parce qu'il ya tout heureusement que
tous les candidats à la présidentielle
et des dépenses tous les programmes
présidentiels il y aura forcément des
dépenses la question c'est pas la
dépense la question c'est quelles
qualités de dépenses on me propose et
surtout comment on finance ses dépenses
nous sommes les seuls en face à mettre
des économies et des économies comeau
par les réformes structurelles la
réforme des retraites c'est vingt cinq
25 milliards d'euros d'économies
là on l'a toujours porté à l'assemblée
nationale hier comme au sénat c'est un
allongement de la durée de cotisation ce
qui permet de maintenir le niveau de
pension d'augmenter les petites
retraites et de s'attaquer aussi aux
carrières une aventure les cotisations
de l'âge de départ à la retraite pardon
de l'âge de départ à la retraite pour
justement éviter quoi une hausse des
cotisations qui est une hausse des
impôts déguisés et pour éviter également
[Musique]
4 c'est quelque chose de progressif on
va pas dire on va dire aux français vous
à droite vous allez tout de suite avoir
un couperet et travailler jusqu'à 65 ans
bien sûr comment ça va se faire
progressif en fonction des catégories
socioprofessionnelles
mais la réforme des retraites elle a
échoué sous le gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'elle était totalement injuste et que
le en même temps n'est pas possible dans
ces réformes là et justement parlé
oui vous avez lancé un sondage 1 pour
essayer déterminer quel serait le
meilleur candidat pour les républicains
l'élection présidentielle d'après les
fuites que l'on a eue hier trois
candidats arriverait au coude à coude
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse michel
barnier est ce que c'est le pire des
scénarios pour jour bon vous avez plus
de filles comme moi d'abord
le sondage sera présenté par christian
jacob et pascal terry non ce soir en
bureau politique
donc j'attends cette présentation là
pour en tirer un certain nombre de
conclusions ce qui m'importe moi c'est
de savoir qui est le mieux placé pour
gagner à droite est la question que tous
les français mais aussi tout l'électorat
de droite doit se poser c qui a le plus
de chances de l'emporter au deuxième
tour face à emmanuel magne et on verra
si un éclairage ce soir ou pas
écouté on verra bien c'est pas à moi de
le dire c'est aux militants et aux
sympathisants et avec torah de droite
votre parti va aussi devoir trancher sur
la question de la tenue des primaires
ouvertes moyennement ouvertes fermées
vous n'y êtes pas forcément favoris mais
d'abord le moyennement ouverte il
n'existe pas il faut pas qu on brouille
le message auprès des ce qu'a proposé
jean louis xi quand même faut pas qu on
brouille le message auprès notre
électorat moi je vais de la clarté la
clarté c'est que la question posée
samedi à nos militants à l'éclair est ce
que oui ou non vous voulez une primaire
la primaire elle est forcément par
essence ouvertes donc soit c'est une
option une qui est de dire on fait une
offre une primaire ouverte à tous les
adhérents sympathisants et à tous les
citoyens qui veulent s'engager dans ce
dans ce processus là soient ensuite on a
une option 2 qui l'option du congrès qui
a ma préférence qui est de ouverte aux
adhérents mais on peut pas avoir un
espèce d'entre d'eux qu'ils viendraient
brouiller les pistes il faut qu'on soit
clair les militants choisissent entre
deux formes à la primaire où le
commerçant leonetti dit en 2017 les
électeurs de gauche qui sont venus
brouiller un peu le scrutin est donc
cette primaire semi fermée c'est pour
éviter cette dérive là mais c'est
l'option une notion une c'est une
primaire ouverte mais avec un certain
nombre de garde-fous je partage et que
j'en étais à proposer et il a raison de
le faire c'est à dire de faire payer un
minimum mais surtout de faire adhérer à
un fichier qui permet tout le monde à
tout le monde de pouvoir s'enregistrer
et surtout qui est la propriété un chef
du parti pour éviter effectivement voilà
ce que vous venez de phénomène que vous
venez d'évoquer mais ça reste une
primaire ouverte
la réalité c'est que c'est ce qu'on a
fait dans tous les partis sauf que vous
on a bien compris un volant d un choix
des militants sauf que dans les deux
favoris et xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse qui ne sont pas adhérents dlr
est-ce que c'est pas un peu paradoxal de
demander à des milles et en l air de
voter pour des candidats qui ne sont pas
l air je comprends que la situation
puisse interroger y compris dans la tête
des militants mais je pense que vous
savez la démocratie c'est simple faut
pas oublier que les militants se sont le
parle c'est le parlement de notre parti
de notre mouvement que je trouve que
c'est mieux de choisir avec eux plutôt
que de choisir entre nous autour d'une
table d'un bureau politique il se trouve
que c'est 5 de le faire alors bien sûr
il ya une situation qui est celle que
vous avez évoquées il faut pouvoir
rassembler au delà de notre famille
politique et c'est aux mines
championnant quelle place pour le centre
si vous faites choisir votre candidat
uniquement par les morales débat je
crois ce soir sur la question de savoir
s'il faut intégrer les adhérents udi ou
centristes la question mérite d'être
posée là dessus mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est important
surtout c'est qu'on ait de la clarté sur
la méthode samedi on ne choisit pas le
candidat samedi ont choisi la méthode de
départage on verra si on a une primaire
ou en congrès une fois qu'on aura fait
cela ensuite effectivement il y aura le
débat sur le choix du candidat mais la
question justement c'est par exemple
quelles sont les chances des xavier
bertrand face à une primaire fermée
alors qu'on voit qu'il a été sifflé au
parc floral lors des journées des jeunes
républicains quelles sont ses chances
dans le cadre il m'a écouté rappelez
vous il ya un ancien puits dans la nuit
qui a été sifflé également par les
militants à l'époque donc elles
s'apprécient s'appelait nicolas sarkozy
et puis moi j'ai vu les journées
parlementaires à nîmes xavier bertrand
est venu devant les députés je veux dire
que non seulement il n'a pas été sifflé
mais il a été largement applaudi parce
que tout le monde a compris la solidité
la détermination et l'envi qu'ils
avaient ils sont pas rares députés à les
dépouiller vote bien sûr mais au delà
l'instant mais ça veut dire que ce qu'il
est capable de faire devant les députés
il est capable de faire devant des
salles militante et donc c'est à lui
ensuite et bien d'aller convaincre les
militants pour tout simplement démontrer
la force de son projet et ce qu'il
attend un peu trop négligé son ancien
parti jours auparavant je crois qu'il ya
eu un rapprochement depuis nîmes pour
moi il ya un avant après nîmes et depuis
nîmes il ya clairement un rapprochement
avec les républicains un rapprochement
qui était souhaitable qu'ils étaient je
crois nécessaire et bienvenue est
aujourd'hui une mi temps de s'interroger
la question ce n'est pas de faire de
prendre une droite qui se fait plaisir
la question c'est de ces nd droite qui
gagne c'est ça qu'on doit trouver et
donc on a la chance d'avoir des
candidats de qualité citer xavier
bertrand il ya michel barnier valérie
pécresse eric ciotti outils et philippe
juvin les cinq sont venus d'ailleurs
devant les députés ils ont tous fait et
sans langue de bois
les prestations donc ça nous montre
qu'on a de la ressource politique en
interne maintenant il pourrait y en
avoir qu'un et c'est important que ce
choix il se fasse entre maintenant et le
4 décembre pour que le 4 décembre on
puisse trancher et avoir un congrès qui
permet de soutenir tel ça veut dire que
si les militants des républicains
choisissez quelqu'un d'autre que des
avis bertrand il devrait s'effacer mais
en tout cas la volonté de tout le monde
et personne personne n'aura une logique
kamikaze pour une raison très simple
c'est que nous sommes aujourd'hui
challenger nous ne sommes plus favorable
on voit bien ce qu'il est en train de se
passer et donc on sait très bien qu'à
deux candidats c'est même pas la peine
d'y aller donc il nous faut une seule
candidature mais je dis aussi cette
candidature unique elle doit se faire
avant noël savez on dit souvent que
c'est mon autour de la dinde de noël on
vend des repas que lequel l'opinion se
cristalliser bien il faut qu'elle se
cristallise autour d'une autre
personne ne veut mais c'est normal ya
une compétition pour le moment mais moi
je sais les relations qui entre les deux
elles sont bonnes je pense qu'il ya une
complémentarité qui est importante et
que tout est possible et que tout est
envisageable y compris ce chemin de
convergence aujourd'hui c'est un peu
michel barnier qui fait débat autour
d'une proposition sur l'immigration il
souhaite un moratoire sur les politiques
migratoires et un référendum qu'est ce
que vous pensez vous à titre personnel
la raison position et je partage
complètement cette position c'est michel
barnier il a ce regard européen qui lui
permet de voir à la fois les faiblesses
et les forces de l'europe et de ne pas
avoir un regard naïf par rapport à ce
que l'europe peut faire quand il dit que
il faut un référendum sur migration vers
les autres candidats le propose
également c'est nécessaire si on veut
par exemple mettre en place les peines
minimales obligatoires pour celles et
ceux qui agressent les policiers ou les
pompiers ou les gendarmes et que quand
ils proposent également d'avoir un
moratoire sur l'immigration il a raison
également pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
on peut pas avoir des flux migratoires
incontrôlées et incontrôlables on peut
pas avoir une europe passoire et que
donc il faut dire la vérité aux français
et aux européens la vérité aux européens
c'est que il faut organiser l'europe des
migrations c'est absolument fondamental
est nécessaire alors autres éléments un
peu perturbant à droite ans et la
candidature d'annecy n'est pas annoncé
mais qui se dessine d'eric zemmour est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
inquiète
examinez république n'est pas un homme
de droite c'est un homme de
d'extrême-droite la deuxième chose que
je voudrais dire c'est que la vision
d'eric zemmour n'est pas la nôtre de la
société française je respecte le
polémiste qu'il est il a un talent très
gai est clair mais je dis aussi une
chose c'est que quand on est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle on est là pour
porter un projet porteur d'espoir et
d'avenir l'ès gimont je porte un projet
porteur de passer et de déclin est ce
qu'il risque pas d'attirer une certaine
frange de votre électorat il le fera si
nous on n'est pas en ordre de bataille
et si nous on est dans nos querelles
internes dans notre tambouille interne
voilà pourquoi j'ai de la réserve comme
vous le savez sur la primaire parce que
je pense qu'on doit parler aux français
et parce que justement il faut pas
laisser le champ libre à quelqu'un comme
eric zemmour voilà je pense que on n'a
pas la même vision de la société
française est d'ailleurs eric zemmour
c'est plus un problème pour marine le
pen et pour le rassemblement national
que pour nous et on le voit dans les
sondages aujourd'hui madame le pen est
en dessous de 20 depuis que eric zemmour
s'est déclaré après vous savez les mules
les bulles médiatiques de septembre ça
fait pas forcément les meilleurs
candidats en janvier est peut-être
encore moins les présidents de la
république en avril ce qui répond pas
aux aspirations d'une partie de votre
respiration qu'on ne peut pas cette mais
vous pensez franchement les cadets
pensais franchement que l'électorat de
droite a envie de quelqu'un avec un
pessimisme absolu qui nous explique la
société française est irréconciliable
qui nous explique que l'affrontement est
inévitable qu'il faut qu'ils nous
expliquent qu'il faut toujours opposés
les uns aux autres qu'on est en
permanence dans la caricature et dans la
repentance je crois pas à ça je pense
qu'un hétéro de droite il a envie de
modernité il envie qu'on lui parle
d'écologie dans vie qu'on lui parle de
fracture territoriale qu'on lui parle
des questions sociales du handicap de la
dépendance tous ces sujets ou eric
zemmour n'existe pas ça électeurs de
droite il n'est pas non plus monocorde
et mono sujet uniquement sur le sujet
sécurité d'immigration il veut que là
dessus on soit ferme mais il a aussi
plein d'autres sujets sur lesquels il a
envie qu'on aborde et qu'on apporte des
réponses ne craignez pas une scission de
notre électorat si par exemple candidats
choisis lors des primaires et de soi et
dans profil un peu trop modéré non je
crois que ce qui créera la fraction
entre électorat c'est l'absence de choix
c'est le brouillage c'est le fait que
long feuilleton trop longtemps et c'est
le fait qu'on n'est pas un candidat est
tous derrière aligner un candidat mais
je suis certain d'une chose c'est que le
jour où on aura un candidat tout le
monde sera derrière et là on rentrera
totalement dans le match et là vous
verrez que je pense qu'on sera non
seulement largement devant exactement
mais surtout la grande différence avec
eric zemmour c'est que l'on n'est pas là
simplement pour faire du buzz médiatique
on est là pour gagner et aujourd'hui les
seuls qui peuvent battre emmanuel macron
c'est la droite république nicolas
sarkozy
bertrand cette semaine on a vu en séance
de dédicaces pour son nouveau livre est
ce que pour vous il doit prendre part au
débat est-ce que ça peut être lui l'
arbitre d'un duel en vue de choisir
votre seul nicolas sarkozy c'est
toujours une boussole politique pour
notre famille c'est le dernier président
de la république de droite c'est un
homme qui a un charisme incroyable et
qui a une vision de la société française
une vision de la france dans le monde
qui doit toujours pour les députés que
nous sommes être importante à écouter et
entendre donc bien sûr que ça sera un
aiguillon après voilà il a fait le choix
fait ce sera un aiguillon que ça peut
être le rassembleur et il a fait le
choix de se retirer de la vie politique
française donc il faut respecter ce
choix là et surtout ne pas faire dire à
nicolas sarkozy chose qui n'a pas dit
soi ce qui n'a pas fait parce qu'il a
beaucoup compté dans sa sphère cela
c'est manger des échanges réguliers avec
lui et je m'astreins à une chose c'est
que j'ai des chances il reste entre lui
et moi est-ce que ce son soutien
vis-à-vis du candidat qui sera choisi ne
fait aucun doute pour vous oui moi je
suis certain que nicolas sarkozy soit
toujours soutenu sa famille politique et
je vois pas pourquoi cela changerait
l'objectif pour lui c'est tout
simplement que la france garde son rang
et donc l'objectif aussi s'est il croit
en la droite républicaine et sage et
aucun doute là dessus maintenant il faut
aussi que la droite républicaine sont en
ordre de bataille et séduisent aussi de
nicolas sarkozy comme l'ensemble des
français merci beaucoup merci merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
cristal on regarde la une de la dépêche
du midi c'est le pass sanitaires et
cette question bientôt la fin du pass
anita recettes à la une de votre journal
merci cristal
[Musique]